i'm danielle and don't underestimate
this california girl
danny it's all about to happen
is third time going to be the charm
i hope so right two losses if i have
another one
i'm definitely never coming back after
this um
i hope so i feel like i have enough
losses under my belt where i've learned
my
my mistakes and everything where this
time this time i can do it what was it
like for you to get the call were you
hesitant
excited shocked um i was
definitely shocked because i came to the
conclusion there would never be an
all-stars it's been
forever and then definitely hesitant
um it was really hard for me to say yes
to be honest um
why i have a daughter now and i've
never been away from her ever ever ever
um
so when i got the call i literally just
started
bawling like weeping not like
crying like weeping and i'm like i'm
happy like i swear
thank you so much i was like i'm just so
sad you know like
typical woman like happy and sad and i'm
like i don't even know what i'm feeling
i don't know what to say
i don't know what to do um i was like i
i feel like i can't leave my daughter
but i also feel like i can't say no so
it was really really hard to make that
decision she's going to be
two next month she has she's a little
one
how much will it affect you that you'll
be
in there without your
husband your daughter will you be
emotionally on edge
oh i'm so emotional i'm not gonna lie my
goal is to not cry all the time
we nobody likes a crier all the time i'm
gonna cry like don't get me wrong
i'm gonna cry my strategy for crying i
have a strategy for crying more than
playing the game
is literally like wake up in the morning
when i'm feeling sad get in the shower
just
cry my eyes out let it all out leave the
shower and leave it all there you know
and just
get back in the game and do that because
i'm gonna cry
like i've already accepted that it's
okay to cry so you're gonna have secret
shower cries
yes i will go talk to some food cry with
some food you know
will you let anybody know how emotional
you are um i'll definitely
let people know to an extent i don't
want people to know
truly how emotional i am but i'll
definitely let every person in there
who's a parent to know
so they can i can relate with them and
we can bond over that for sure
well you're gonna find new ways to bond
with people this time around
um you're in a different place but
you've always had a kind of a
strong emotional connection uh or
emotional story on the show i mean
you had a showmance before now you're
not gonna be able to do that what that's
what's that gonna be like for how you
connect with people
um i think coming in this time it's my
whole goal is to walk in that house and
just start flattering people and you
know drown them in compliments everyone
loves a compliment
and build that rapport and those bonds
with people
and that's really important i think that
we all share the same experience that
nobody else can share
and it's gonna be a whole new game you
know i connect really well with people
like people genuinely like me in real
life
and i think i just need to portray that
in the game
and get them to want to keep me around
because they like me i think that's
very very important in the beginning i'm
danielle i'm also
21. i told everyone that i was 21 i have
less than two months until my 21st
birthday i just didn't want to be like
the one person who was underage
so what did your husband think about you
going on is he gonna miss you
or is he gonna are you gonna talk to him
through the live feeds so you know you
think he knows you're thinking about him
oh yeah i'm gonna be that annoying
person who's like talking on the live
feeds embarrassing myself
when i'm always like this person's
annoying crying
talking to the live feeds um definitely
yeah my husband
is seriously the greatest human ever
like he's so supportive
he's so understanding he's put up with
so much like getting ready for all of
this
and i'm so lucky to have him been so
blessed to have him
and um he's definitely sad
he acts all tough but he's really a
[ __ ] he'll be mad at me for saying that
but uh he's really sad i'm not gonna be
there but he's just
literally taken over and you know taking
care of our daughter at home and
everything else so
he's an all-star so what do you want to
prove this time
um i think everyone has a thing to prove
i mean
i i want to prove that i can win you
know like my goal is to go in there and
win
i think that when it's not all stars a
lot of people want to make it to jury or
do this and that like i want to freaking
win that show i want to be the winner of
all stars
like i want to
i want to dethrone the bb queen and be
known as
the bb queen you know like that's what i
want
i want people to recognize my game and
see me as the best female player that's
ever played the game
oh right powerful words i love that yes
we're manifesting that yes
um how do you think it will affect the
game that everyone is coming off of
this crazy time in our world being
locked up and quarantined
the political climate we have everything
that's happening could this be the most
intense season ever
i think it's actually going to be the
most intense season for other reasons
i think that covid and all that other
stuff i don't think that it's really
going to play a part in the game
a lot of people have asked me you know
being in the big brother house before is
that like being
you know in quarantine because of copen
and it's not even comparable
like literally it's not you're at home
chilling with your family watching tv
going on walks bike rides like
big brother's intense you know like and
you're surrounded by people you
hate so it's nothing like that it does
not prepare anyone for that
um so i think it's just gonna be super
intense for other reasons like everyone
i think is gonna be very cutthroat
everyone is gonna be walking around the
house like they know everything and
they're better than everybody because
i've played with people who played
before and that's what they do
and i think that a lot of people are
going to destroy their own games
um how do you think they'll do that um
like i said everyone
walks around that house when they've
played before and they have this god
complex like they're better than
everyone
and they put people down and talk down
to people and
everyone in there i know is gonna have a
huge personality
and some of us like when people talk to
me like that i'm not gonna put up with
it you know i'm gonna be nicer about it
than other people
because i'm not gonna get kicked out for
it but i'm happy to put people in their
place
it sounds like you're heading into this
more savage than ever
i am to be honest okay so my first game
i was a liar and a backstabber
my second game i went in there and i
played with my heart i played with
people i loved and i actually liked
i was super honest and it did not get me
far and
this season oh my god like i am not
afraid to stab anybody
i'm going to be you should just call me
the beach umbrella because i am going to
be very shady
well uh it sounds like you went into
this uh preparing did you watch other
seasons
um or what kind of work did you do
before you you got sequestered
i have been watching seasons because you
know once you have a kid and stuff i
don't have free time on my hands so like
when i watch the show
like one season i was literally in labor
for the show and i stopped watching
and this and that i missed some episodes
and you watch different like oh who won
this competition
you know i was in a showmance like a
casual viewer and i'm like
these people are gonna be like they're
all crazy big brother encyclopedias like
i need to brush up a little bit so i've
been trying to like
power through all of them and re-watch
them so i'm gonna be sick of these
people before i see them in real life
anyone you're excited to see anyone you
would dread to see
um excited to see it's hard to say
because like all the people i'm really
close with i know are not gonna be in
the house which is super sad
um i think like eric stein from big
brother eight i think he's
beyond deserving i one of my closest
friends kalia i'd love to see there i
know they're not in there
um so i really don't know who i'd like
to see in there
um just anyone i have any kind of bond
with and who's like i think is a nice
person to work with
um who i don't want to see the list is
so long i'd have to pull out a book for
you
um but if i had to pick one person i'd
probably say paul
only because i've met him in real life
and he's a very nice person but i don't
like his game i think that he
is a bully and not nice in the game and
i don't want to fight with anybody at
least for a long time that's my goal
so if there's somebody who i don't you
know who would like egg me on like i
just don't want to fight with people
so i'd say you don't want to be uh
set off too soon yes my last question
for you because it's been
so long since the last all-star season
there are some people probably who
you're going to see you haven't been on
the show in years and then there's me
yeah right yeah and then there's going
to be some people who
might be newer who do you think has the
bigger advantage
um to be totally honest with you i think
that the newer people have
such a big advantage um they've played
recently it's in their blood i know a
lot of them have done the
challenge on mtv so they're continuing
to do
reality shows it's very familiar for
them it's been nine years for me
they have these bonds when you come out
of the house you're always introducing
yourself to newer house guests like
because you have that bond
i haven't played in nine years i'm not
that person who goes like
loved you on the show on twitter blah
blah blah be my friend like i
i'm i haven't played in nine years i'm
not gonna reach out to people like i'm
sorry but that makes me feel like a
desperate loser like
that's just not who i am so i think i
have a huge disadvantage but i also
think
i'm hoping that there's a lot of the
more old school players at least some of
them
because i think that we can share that
bond over it of being old people
you know like playing the old original
big brother game
yeah there's definitely a difference in
you know the social media
theme you get the connections these days
yeah there was no instagram when i went
on big brother the first time like
that makes me sound like so old um but
it's it's so different it's a different
world like
on big brother eight i went on not for
fame not for anything which is a lot of
the reasons they go on now but
i went on just for a fun experience like
you want a little change in life reality
tv wasn't
anything what it is now and it's it's so
different
it's so different i i'll be honest i'd
kind of like to see somebody more old
school take down a newbie
right i would too i really really was
you